It seems like there might also be a ton
of other considerations if you're
thinking about hearing impairment,
visual impairment.
When people are designing for all these
users can you compromise the design?
Will the product maybe change too much?
>> Yeah, it's a very good question and
there definitely does
seem like there's a lot at first
glance to really consider.
And in actuality,
if you do leave all these considerations
to the end of the product cycle,
it can compromise the product because
there's a lot of rethinking and
refactoring that needs to go in,
to just kind of fit these things in.
And so that's why we're always
asking people, and informing,
and educating people on how to
think of these things early on.
I think when you just look at the
general steps within the design process,
all of the points that when you're
thinking about accessibility,
they're integrated in every step
that you're already thinking about.
So again, with color contrast,
you're already thinking about what
is your color palette going to be.
So, then just on top of that you have
some additional standards to maybe try
to follow and look at to ensure
that there's enough contrast there.
Hey, we're here at the OXO website.
I wanted to bring this up because I
feel like they have a really good
approach to universal design, and
they have this great quote on
here that I wanted to read.
When we talk about designing for
accessibility or universal design,
it's important to note that that does
not mean designing products fully usable
by everybody,
since there is no product that can
truly fulfill the needs of all users.
But, when all users' needs are taken
into consideration in the initial
design process,
the result is a product that can be
used by the broadest spectrum of users.
So, I feel like that's a great
way to kind of sum up that, yes,
there is a lot to consider, but
it's not about making compromises.
In the end, when you do
consider these things up front,
you end up with a better
product overall.
>> Yeah, that's great.
And how can an entrepreneur
learn more about accessibility?
What resources are available to them?
>> The great thing is there's a lot
of resources out there online.
A few just to kind of rattle off,
are the Web Content Accessibility
Guidelines, which you can find online.
That's a really thorough list of
standards that you would want to meet,
and need to meet.
And they have great examples on
there as well, and resources.
Different companies have provided
their own design guidelines.
Google is one of them,
which you can see here.
This is the Google Accessibility website
and specifically these are our design
guidelines that we came up with, which
are based on a lot of the standards
that were developed by the Web
Content Accessibility Guidelines.
Apple has a great resource as well, for
their accessibility design guidelines.
And there's also some really
interesting tools out there.
There's plugins.
There's a plugin called SEE that allows
you to kind of simulate what your
page or site would look like with
different vision impairments,
as well as color blindness.
Yeah, so there's a lot that's out there.
>> Great.